[Musique]
à
s'ils étaient sur le pont d'un navire se
serait sans doute celui d'une galère il
est 17 rescapés de leurs autres outre
entament leur septième et avant-dernière
journée de marche
ce n'est plus vraiment à lever aux
aurores mais enlever aux forces origines
mais ces clubs qui désormais légendaire
première épreuve du jour
enfiler ses chaussures
gentiment tout cela isabelle tes
origines mille baudrier régime pour
décerner les échelles un concentré
nouveau jeu conséquent même si la tâche
comme ça me met hors jeu quand on va à
près de tartines
[Musique]
oh
ça va tous les matins gp alors qu'ils
vivent au milieu de la glisse et
[Musique]
régis par l'étape du jour est la plus
alpine du parcours on quitte le nid
d'aigle de bertholle pour atteindre à
3700 m
le sommet de têtes blanches le point
culminant de la route roues sur le
papier mais sur le papier seulement
zermatt n'est plus qu'à une encablure
d'emploi glaciers 1 pendant un bon
moment on va se rendre à tête blanche
ses remparts est d'un savant tranquille
mais on va quand même compter trois
heures et c'est qu'on lève la première
pause c'est entre 6h28 est 6h45
ouais bien dans cette
[Musique]
regardez
non
[Musique]
et c'est pareil et notre ami paul qui
veut faire un grand pas pour rentrer
dans sa 76e année et qui à 75 ans à
cette harpe et autres ouais
[Musique]
ah ah ah
merci je rembourserai cre est réservé
je peux je peux pas exprimer mes
sentiments main oui il ya une langue qui
reçoit paul et cuisine visites pour
ponséro allez encore une part allez on y
va
allez vas tu sois là on y va allez
faisons ensemble
allez un peu d'émotion ça fait du bien
au levain et froid le soleil six jours
de marche compteur la veille déjà
monique la québécoise était allé puiser
dans ses réserves
aujourd'hui ses jambes ne la porte lui
c'est désormais sa tête qui a pris le
relais
on appelle ça naviguer dans le rouge
ça marche mal en carton comme ça
attends je suis pas dans les pas la fin
je garde les mêmes potes lui pour ce
vent me gêne
[Musique]
j'ai plus d'énergie
je pousse fort du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coupe de 5 euros je tiens bien le
patriciat on a tous boire un coup mais
chut que je veux je suis bien à jour on
respire transforme avec le vent voilà je
pense que la fatigue chez certes elles
s'accumulent de jour en jour et axa 3
cumulés aujourd'hui c'est un peu dur
mais on ne l'a moi j'ai quand même des
médicaments au cas où
[Musique]
après sept jours d'efforts
comme avec la limite ô combien excitante
du raisonnable chacun savoure enfin ce
qu'il attend depuis son départ de
chamonix sa majesté le savent
[Musique]
alex
cameron
ce coquin de données
[Musique]
3410 avant même les soldes à 3718 mills
et robuste avec des clients comme ça
c'est facile
condom ce qu'au niveau n'a eu d'yeux
je savais que ça allait être une épreuve
à quelque part pour moi mais je me
disais qu'à force de volonté devrait y
arriver mais ça a été encore plus dur
puisque j'attendais quand je me suis
écrasé j'avais l'impression qu'il
restait plus rien du tout du tout du
tout où pu visiter on apprend chaque
jour quelque chose quand on est à en
conflit avec la nature s'épanouit le
patron on est tout petit mais je pense
que tant l'effort dans la difficulté
t'es jamais tout seul le gars jouer i'm
a écrasé la manne des moments très très
très fort mais leur mission sécher avec
le vent du nord pour les matins prochain
au moment où on a eu cette étreinte
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'en passer
mon grand père que j'ai adoré et il est
décédé et épaules lui ressemble
tellement dans sa finesse dans sa
discrétion et j'ai eu tout d'un coup
j'étais habité par une émotion mais un
temps jeu une bouffée d'amour et je suis
mais c'est pas possible c'est c'est pas
paul que j'embrassais mon grand père
c'est et j'ai vraiment fondu en larmes
à ce moment là paul lui sait pas du tout
ce qui m'arrivait et il m'a tout de
suite dit je te comprends
après je lui dis tu sais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est là
puis me dit mais il est là il est l'un
tu voi l'ombre des nuages qui vient
caresser le flanc de la montagne et bien
c'est ton grand père qui vient caresser
la joue à la vie dame en écosse ce plan
[Musique]
j'ai pas pu me contrôler et là la vente
elle m'a dit non non ce topic
maintenant tu te lâches
ni radio froid aux pieds c'est bouger
bien les orteils pour les maintenir en
vie
on y va
john lennon faire doucement ça va me
tricaud maurice
[Musique]
alors je me suis dit bon plaisir dans
les formes si le plaisir est dans
l'effort il ya tout de même des limites
à ne pas dépasser
depuis six jours un pic à ranger sa
bière fermentée souffrent en silence son
genou gauche est sur le point de le
lâcher
éval
je loue
toufik je crois qu'on va arrêter là
parce que voilà quoi si on descend trop
lentement ça va pas aller puis toi qui
vas tu va encore aggraver sa blessure
pour le groupe c'est pas facile non plus
et tout proche du butin je sais même pas
ce que j'ai et tu vois ça fait super mal
j'encaisse le bon
[Applaudissements]
là
et
oh c'est pas un échec total quoi j'ai
que voilà c'est la santé c'est dangereux
mais j'ai même pu la rall parce que j'ai
voulu terminer
le bia sinistre sans doute l'un des plus
beaux les halles mais peut-être aussi
l'un des plus dangereux
[Musique]
yannick ramasser des bonnes crevasse
dans la corde c'est bien tendu là
[Musique]
ici il ya des crevasses tranparence les
énormités et là il y en a plein on est
sur des ponts énorme
il ya déjà des cathédrales i ci dessous
bon il a une qui se cache même pas en
hiver celle d'en bas mais ici c'est très
crevasses et là là on en voit sortir là
bas aussi ça commence puis d'ici un mois
vont sa source à s'ouvre
[Musique]
oui
clin d'oeil du sud est déjà grand
regardez la corde tendue alors ici pour
ce faire les jeunes espoirs
non non ce sera difficile parce cap sur
plots faut que tu te mettes assez droite
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu chez vous et des cathédrales
[Musique]
dans le jargon des montagnards on
appelle ça un terrain casse pattes
à première vue un passage tout ce qui
est des plus anodins mais si pour les
randonneurs l'apéritif n'est plus qu'à 2
aux mains pour les bim pas question de
relâcher une minute sur leur attention
les pieds pour les enfants le corps il
avait extrait voulait charger vos
cuperly volt est vraiment à quoi qu'un
profiteur
j'appelle bush avoue je viens
je me ravi d'être ici
épié
je
[Applaudissements]
babès les fier voila voila tu fais les
pays bas
oui
dir
parce que j'y retrouve sans cailloux
mais qui sort ici
votre choix
[Musique]
non
c'est parfait pour glisser sur dernière
ça sent la fin
[Musique]
laquelle
alors juste
[Musique]
non
les rouges et des cabanes comme cela est
ok merci mérite bien joué j'hésite à
faire à baie saint paul alors comment le
vol mais fatigué
ça fout les boules
movies ram au débat appremment souffre
tranquillement savourer le soleil voir
quelque chose
oh oui je le suis ces tirs rolala ados
toujours oui c'est vrai que française
mais s'avère trimestre
en lacets
c'était meurtrier bord un panneau c'est
le fera encore disputer
je
train de changer
ce jeu
et voilà
laporta le pont de neige qui tombe
dessus grâce à sa soins de tous les
côtés si toi tu pas trop fait trop
violente
non non non et été suspendu la wicca
attaché pistes étaient encordés
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir la corde vendus
je suis descendu d'un coup tout droit
j'ai fermé les yeux et je les aient
rouvert une fois que j'ai senti que
j'étais bien 1 6 3
après tu te dis a plus qu'à attendre le
mec est tout seul qui tombe maintenant
je te dis jamais envie de rire parce que
je me disais ya qu une bourde à faire
moi qui à faire
c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie je
peux me direz vous je vous le dis du
fond du coeur
ce serait un magnifique qu'est ce que
j'ai vu partager avec vous les amis ici
pendant huit neuf jours
j'ai appris beaucoup pour cause pourtant
j'aime qu'on va prendre parce que bien
sûr maintenant vu que j'ai atteint stoch
de 75 ans je suis parti pour les entend
pourquoi pas merci beaucoup
une fois trouvée devant apprendre à
s'accorder
l'occasion leur fut proposé ça va
traverser gémonies à zermatt depuis
matin à 4h du mat phibro skoda se met en
route pour faire la route entre chamonix
et zermatt
[Applaudissements]
au spi force d'esprit encore on célèbre
aussi cette aventure nous a remarqué
pour l'éternité du conte jack et belz et
puis celui qui se la pètent et
finalement ce sont tous ces groupes ont
des petits bobos
le groupe compte fait il ya cinq manades
france du lycée canada sa cavale ne faut
voir ça on en est là bas
on finit cette chanson remercier nos
compagnons et en disant défaut en
vigueur retour certain retour à la
civilisation c'est l'heure des bilans
si c'était à refaire 6,6 tout à fait
important si leur feraient pas moi je
leur ferais pas ça c'est si n'importe
qui peut le faire si on n'a pas du
caractère je sais pas si on arrive
jusqu'au bout
elle leur a dit
je suis simplement heureux que j'ai pu
rentrer dans cette montagne et j'en suis
ressorti ça m'a impressionné
mais quand je vois quand on est tous
dans le même bain que voilà on fera tout
notre pied justement à cette galère là
il y as fierté d'avoir combattu des
inquiétudes je dirais on peut marcher
on peut marcher ici on peut marcher les
dans sa vie
je trouve c'est bien si j'ai pu discuter
avec des adultes et puis j'ai vu que le
point de vue c'était pas que c'était pas
comme dans les films ça ça m'a prouvé
que oui c'était parce que j'étais encore
capable de rentrer en contact comme ça
sans trop me prendre la tête
le masque est tombé en fait j'espère
maintenant j'espère qu'il va pas revenir
je suis venu avec un petit physique un
petit moral et je repars avec des
cuissons béton est un monstre papattes
comme on dit chez vous moi si j'avais dû
parier au départ de chamonix
combien arrive au but j'aurais sûrement
perdu mon pari pari gagné prono
randonneurs qui ont partagé un rêve un
peu un rêve mais surtout une furieuse
envie d'aller au bout d'un voyage qui
les aura manqué à vue huit jours de
marche entre chamonix et zermatt
elodie fidèle à sa légende
[Musique]